our subject for this evening public and
private what did i say
public and private
let not your heart be troubled
you believe in god
believe also in me
in my father's house on many mansions
if it were not so i would have told you
i go to prepare a place for you
and if i go and prepare a place for you
i will come again
and receive you unto myself
that where i am
there ye may be also
and whether i go ye know
and the way he know
thomas said unto him
lord
we know not wither thou goest and how
can we know the way
jesus said unto him
i am the way
the truth
and the life
no man cometh unto the father
but by me
if he had known me
you should have known my father also
and from henceforth you know him
and have seen him philip said unto him
lord
show us the father
and it sufficeth us
jesus saith unto him
have i been so long time with you and
yet hast thou not known me philip you
that have seen me
have seen the father
and house says thou then
shows the father
believers thou not
that i am in the father
and the father in me
the words that i speak unto you
i speak not of myself
but the father that dwelleth in me he
doeth the works
believe me that i am in the father
and the father in me
or else believe me for the very work's
sake
verily verily i say unto you
he that believeth on me the works that i
do shall he do also
and greater works than thee shall he do
because i go unto my father
and whatsoever he shall ask in my name
that will i do
that the father may be glorified in the
son
if he shall ask anything
in my name
i will do it
if
you love me
keep
my commandments
god is good
and all the time
psalm 100 5
for the lord is
good
and as i like to say
when god blesses us
he's good
when he punishes us come on talk to me
when he answers our prayers
when he says no
he's good the lord cannot be anything
but good
the bible says in psalm 145 verse 17 the
lord is righteous in all his ways
and holy
in all his works by the way that's the
way we ought to be psalm 106 verse 3
blessed are they that keep judgment and
he that doeth righteousness at
all times
in other words there is no exception to
god's goodness
there should be no exception to our
righteousness
or living like jesus christ i'm
delighted to be with you this evening i
welcome those of you also online
wherever you are
we thank god for the capability to reach
the four corners of the world
one man stands in chestertown and speaks
and people listen in various countries
we're grateful for that and we ask god
to continue to guide us and lead us that
we may make maximum use of this
technology to take the gospel to the
four corners of the world so those of
you online thank you very much is anyone
present now who is not a seventh-day
adventist raise your hand
sister mary god bless you
thanks for coming again i say that from
this my heart thank you so much the
bible says he that endureth until the
end the same shall be saved so we look
for you sister mary all the way until
sabbath evening i'm sure there's someone
online who is not a seventh-day
adventist if i'm speaking to you thank
you very much for listening and i hope
god tells me something to tell you that
will change your life i want you to
believe as you listen that i am speaking
to you personally and not the thousands
of people because the gospel is a matter
of personal salvation are you with me
mind character and personality volume 2
page 4 23 paragraph 2 the gospel deals
with
individuals and i love to stress this
i love to stress it god made adam and
eve at separate times he did not make
them together
when he made the courts of skins he made
two
one for each
salvation
is a personal matter if you understand
what i just said say amen
all right
our subject for this evening public and
private what did i say
public and private what was our subject
yesterday morning
from genesis
to revelation
as always let me trouble you by asking
you to preserve reference you did an
excellent job yesterday those of you
online also preserve reference i know
you're at your homes so it's a relaxed
environment as well it should be but god
is always god are you following me
and god is a holy god and at all times
deserves
reference
we give reference to earthly leaders let
us give reference to god so if you're
not using one of these as a
bible please make sure it does not ring
let me check mine before you say
physician heal thyself all right mine is
turned off
fear number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth
how many of you prayed for me yesterday
can i see your head uh thank you
when i say god bless you
it's a prayer i'm offering with my eyes
open and the prayer has three words god
bless you and i'm not joking so for
those of you who prayed god bless you
for those of you who have not yet prayed
please hurry up and give me a reason to
say god bless you
the reason i ask you to pray for me is
based on jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9
which says then the lord put forth his
hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth and i want to
speak truly god's words favor number
three think as you're listening isaiah
118 come now let us reason together set
the lord jeremiah 12 verse 5 god says to
us as he calls us to reason if thou has
run with the footmen
and they have weary thee
how then canst thou contend with the
horses what is god saying if you cannot
keep up with a man how do you intend to
keep up with a horse he is calling upon
us use the common sense i have given you
because god's religion has a major
component of simple common sense
let's pray father in heaven thank you
for this lovely day
thank you for the chill in the air
because we have to be alive to feel
chilly
so we thank you we can feel the cold we
thank you we can hear the message there
god
and we thank you for freedom of worship
that still exists in this blessed
country and other countries represented
by those listening but above all dear
god we thank you for the gift of your
dear son jesus christ
as we bow before you father
if we've sinned against you we ask you
to forgive us dear god
calvary exists that you might forgive
and be just in so doing
they god i humble myself before you and
i ask you in the name of your son my
savior speak
throw me their god
grant me the humility of jesus christ
then i will do what the spirit tells me
to do
i will say what he tells me to say when
he tells me to say it
bless those whom you love so much in
this building and online who are
listening now reveal truth to them their
god in the power of simplicity
and let decisions be made to obey christ
bless this country bless every country
represented by those listening remind
the leaders their god
that righteousness exalted the nation
if anyone listening to me has covered 19
father in the name of your son the great
physician heal those persons i pray
bless all the little children who may be
listening boys and girls let them know
father that it pleases you when they
give their lives to you now dear god we
commit this service to your glory i pray
in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen
go with me to matthew chapter 5 our
subject public and private
matthew chapter 5 we read from verse 38
it's 7 13 i'll release you before 8
o'clock
and i want to make that a guaranteed
promise before 8 o'clock
do you have matthew chapter 5 yes
all right we have one brother who has it
anybody else has it
okay
let's read from verse 38 of matthew 5
and i read from the king james version
of the bible if you have it you may read
with me
you have heard that it had been said
an eye for an eye
and a tooth for a tooth
but i say unto you
yet he resist not evil
but whosoever shall smite thee on the
right she finish that verse turn to him
the other also and if any man will sue
thee at the law
and take away thy coat
let him have thy cloak also and
whosoever shall walk compel thee to go
mild go with him twin what is jesus
saying
jesus is telling us as much as possible
live peaceably with everybody which is
what paul tells us in romans 12 21 we
will get to that in the days of christ a
roman soldier can compel a jew to carry
his baggage one mile
jesus says go too
a lot of families are broken up because
someone is not willing to go the extra
mile
both people are right and someone will
not go the extra mile many accidents
occur because i got to the intersection
first
and you pulled off and you shouldn't so
i pull out we have an accident because i
was right
we must learn as children of god to go
the extra mile to preserve peace
abraham when he and lord had to separate
he gave not first choice that's going
the extra mile
lot you choose even though that
privilege rightfully belonged to abraham
when adam and eve sinned god could have
said come to me and make it right but he
didn't he went the extra mile to the
extent he became one of us can you say
amen to fix this conflict between god
and his creation
and whosoever
shall compel thee to go a mile
go with him
twain christ is saying do what's
necessary to get along when he sent out
the disciples in matthew 10 he said to
them in verse 16 behold i send you forth
as sheep in the midst of wolves
be therefore wise the serpents
and harms his doves
let me digress shortly slightly christ
did not tell the wolves how to treat the
sheep
are you with me
he told the sheep
find a way
to get along
with the wolves
whom do we have in this building tonight
sheep or wolves
come on sheep
we must get along with the unbeliever as
much as possible
unless if god's law is because he
becomes the focus then we ought to obey
god rather than man we must learn to get
along with the government as far as
possible until god's law is threatened
jesus said be therefore wise as serpents
and harmless as dove he puts the burden
on you and on me to get along with our
satanic supervisor
on the job
in other words christ is saying
in moments of stress act like me
act like me
when christ stood before pilate in john
18 verse 36 he said jesus answered my
kingdom is not of this world
if my kingdom were of this world then
would my servants fight
that i should not be delivered to the
jews but now is my kingdom not from
heads christ is saying the kingdom over
which i am the ruler we don't cite
it's difficult to swallow that because
the carnal nature loves to fight
but we're called to be like jesus
not like the carmel nature we're not
called to be like the first adam we're
called to be like the last adam jesus
christ now let's say in matthew 5 let's
go down to verse 43 our subject public
and private
let me pray again
holy father in heaven as i make this
attempt to speak for you
enable me i pray through an infilling
of your holy spirit in jesus name i
appeal to you amen
matthew 5 43 you have heard that it have
been said
thou shalt love thy neighbor and hate
that enemy but i say unto you what
love your enemies bless them that curse
you do good to them there
and pray for them which despitefully use
you and persecute you that ye may be the
children of your father come on
you are in heaven
that's how a child of god behaves
you curse me
i bless you let's read that verse again
you're looking at me as i'm reading a
different book from the one you have
matthew 5 43
if you have my version ready with me you
have heard that it had been said thou
shalt love thy neighbor and hate thine
enemy but i say unto you what
love your enemies come on
bless them that will curse you do good
to them that hate you and pray for them
which despitefully use you and perky boy
that he may be the children of your
father
which is in heaven yes
that's how children of god behave
there's abuse coming around us we take
it
we take it
because it takes two hands to clap
you didn't get what i just said
you can't clap with one hand
it takes two to have a quarrel
jesus said don't contribute
there's a heavenly principle that the
police that forces use
a soft answer come on
now if someone is held hostage and a
hostage negotiator goes to talk to the
criminal he does not shout
am i talking to myself are you listening
to him he does not shout let them go or
blow your hair off he doesn't do that
because that will act in it
exacerbate
he talks softly he tries to find out his
name
your name is randy okay randy john paul
whomever nebuchadnezzar don't do that
he's soft
it works because a soft answer turneth
away roth many years ago i studied
martial arts
i was quite good at it too
but don't let that intimidate you i
don't use it when i make appeals
the thing that i love most about the
martial was not the fighting of the
kicks no it was
stay calm
at all times stay calm because the one
who's calm has the advantage
if you're calm
the hostile person
will eventually calm down
if you respond aggressively then
aggression and aggression is aggression
squared
jesus said
bless them that curse you do good to
them that they spitefully use you and
pray for them
so when the public treats us badly
we must respond with good are you
following me
let's go to romans 12.
our subject public and private
romans 12 we'll read from verse 19 i
believe it is 19 years
do you have that
romans 12 written by the apostle paul
reading from verse 19 what does that
verse say
dearly beloved avenge not yourself but
rather give place unto wrath for it is
written
vengeance is mine i will repay said the
lord stop
read that quietly to yourselves
vengeance
is mine
you know why
only god can read this
we cannot fully understand why people do
to us what they do we cannot read the
heart uh accurately god can and so god
says vengeance is mine i will repay
because god can accurately determine
what degree of response that person
deserve we cannot do that the let the
beloved avenge not yourselves but rather
give place unto wrath for it is written
vengeance is mine
i will repay now let's keep reading
therefore if thine enemy hunger
feed him
if he thirsts
give him a drink
for in so doing thou shall he calls a
fire on his head read verse 21 49 nice
allowed be not overcome of evil
but overcome evil with good let's look
at that principle
that was spoken by christ
listen again
most christians don't follow it that's
my guess
be not overcome
of evil
overcome evil with good
look at verse 20
therefore if thy enemy hunger feel it
someone has done you something bad do
something good if he thirsts give him
drink do not respond in kind but all of
that is on the outside you see that's
public someone slaps you turn the cheek
that's on the outside that has nothing
to do with you are you following me you
did not
cause that behavior wicked people do
wicked things it is natural to them so
that's public
listen to verse 21 of romans 12 again
say it for me
be not overcome
of evil
but overcome evil with good now what's
the subject of tonight's message
come on come on come on
public
and pray
let's drop the public for a minute okay
let's forget the evil people who do us
bad listen to me carefully
be not overcome of evil
question for you if no one ever does
anything wrong is there an evil we need
to overcome
talk to me
in here
what's our subject
let's get to the private now there's an
evil in us
and the bible says it ought to be
overcome how
with good
does that mean well let's see what that
means
we must overco you see the evil that is
worse is not what people do to us
it is the fact
that there is none righteous no not one
are you not with me
my fault maybe i'm standing too far from
you perhaps i'll talk from there
tomorrow night
um richie more effectively listen to me
carefully my friends online
if someone
robs you at the store steals your car
yes that's evil
that's not what takes you to hell
someone takes over your boyfriend twice
someone in the church talks badly about
you because that person wanted a deacon
supposition that's not what takes you to
hell it is not the evil people do to us
that endangers our salvation it is the
evil
within but both must be dealt with the
same way be not overcome of evil but
overcome evil with good now we have
dispense with the public kind of evil
that's done to us we're looking at the
evil we do to ourselves
it's my sin
jesus says overcome that
with good
but let's look at this good
let's go to romans three our subject
public and private
romans 3
is 725.
we're ready for verse
10 of romans 3.
i'll pray again father as i continue
let your spirit restrain me i pray in
jesus name amen
do you have romans chapter 3 yes from
verse 10
what does that say
as it is written there is none righteous
no not one
there's none that understand it there's
none that seeketh after god they are all
to what
god another way they are together become
unprofitable finish verse 12 there is
none that doeth good nor not one stop
what did jesus say about handling evil
it must be overcome with what
with good
what did paul just say
verse 12
there is none that does good
let's try to fix this problem
go with me to galatians 5.
let's read verse 22 and 23 verses 22 and
23 our subject public and private are
you there
but the fruit of the spirit is read with
me love joy
peace long suffering gentleness goodness
faith meekness tempers now do we have
goodness in that list
yeah yes
where does it come from
look at verse 22
it is a fruit come on
of the spirit
how are we born
come on how are we born
what
how are we born
the clue is spirit we're looking at the
gifts of the spirit but how are we born
someone say without the spirit you're
right we're carnal
let's look at that go to verse 19 of
galatians 5.
when i ask you a question i want you to
answer me
well i'll keep asking you
until you change your behavior
galatians 5 do you have that
all right let's read verse 19.
now the words of the flesh are manifest
which are these
adultery fornication
uncleanness lasciviousness
idolatry witchcraft hatred variants
emulations wrath strife seditions
heresies envyings murders drunkenness
revelings and such light stuff
those are the the works of the flesh are
you with me
now let's read what we just read verse
22 23 read with me but the fruit of the
spirit is love joy peace long suffering
gentleness goodness faith meekness
temperance stop
how many lists do we have
two
in what verses do we have the first list
take a
no no in look
verses do we have the first list as it
occurs in that chapter
19 come on
to 21. where do we have the second list
22 and 23. now what do you notice about
those two lists give me one word that
describes them
opposites
opposites flesh and spirit absolutely
now
jesus said
be not overcome with evil but finish the
verse overcome
all right let's look at the carnal
nature now let's see let's try to find
some goodness let's look at that list
again
we're looking for goodness
verse 19 come on read with me but the
works of the flesh are adultery
fornication
uncleanness lasciviousness idolatry
witchcraft hatred variants emulations
wrath strife seditions
end things murders drunkenness revelings
and such like do we have anything is any
one of those things a good thing yes or
no no
is the law against those things yes
that's where we are naturally
that's the way we are naturally until
christ changes us
we're born that way
not doing all of them but having the
capacity to do them
we're born the bible says because the
carnal mind is enmity against god for it
is not
subject to what the law of god
which means it is against the law of god
the carnal mind
but listen to verses 22 and 23 again our
subject public and private
read with me but the fruit of the spirit
is love joy peace long suffering
gentleness goodness faith meekness
temperance now finish 23
against such there is no law
is there a law against 19-21
is there a law in favor of 22 and 23 yes
listen to romans 8
because the carnal mind is enmity
against god for it is not subject to the
law of god what is it subject to verse
19 to 21
now we have to overcome 19 through 21
with what
to 23.
are you looking at me as though i need
medication come on are you with me
yes we must overcome 19 to 21 with
22 to 23
but
we've seen
that there's no goodness in our flesh
we saw in romans 3 verse 12 there's none
that do does good listen to paul for i
know that in me that is in my flesh
dwelleth come on talk to me no good
thing that jesus said you've got to
overcome evil with good
where's the source of that goodness
let's find out go to romans chapter 2.
our subject public and private
am i going too quickly
if i am just say slow down i have a
tendency to go quickly
so please if you love me a little bit
just say preacher slow down
are you at romans 2.
let's read verse 4 are you there
read with me if you have my version or
despises now the riches of his goodness
and what forbearance and long-suffering
not knowing that the goodness of god
leadeth thee to repentance how often
have we seen the word goodness in that
verse
come on look closely
how many times is the word goodness in
that verse
twice let's read it again or despise us
now the riches of his goodness and
forbearance and long-suffering god
goodness is a natural quality of god
let's go to exodus 34. let's go there
quickly exodus 34.
in chapter 33 moses said i beseech thee
show me thy glory verse 30 chapter 33
verse 18. now god comes down to show him
what he needs to see
he wants to see god's brightness god
will show him his character that's what
we need to see god shines brightness in
his character
exodus 34 from verse 5 and the lord
descended in the cloud and stood with
him there and proclaimed the name of the
lord and the lord passed by before him
and proclaimed the lord the lord god
read with me now
merciful and gracious come on long
suffering abundant in what goodness and
true god is abundant in goodness we read
in romans 2 4 the riches of his goodness
what did jesus say how should we
overcome evil
with good
do we have any good yes or no
no come on say no loudly do we have any
goodness sinners no
but we have to overcome evil with good
where can we get that goodness
jesus
let me show you where goodness is again
go to romans 7 another source of
goodness which is really the same thing
romans 7
let's read verse 12
our subject public and private
do you have romans 7
we're taking you from exodus to romans
romans 7
verse 12.
read that for me my version what does
that say
wherefore the law is holy and the
commandment holy
just and good
law of god
is good
amen
because it expresses
the very righteousness
of christ listen to me again
the law of god is good that is why
when god converts a man or a woman
he takes the law
and writes it where
on the heart
where is the evil
where's the evil
come on where's the now what does god do
to get rid of the evil you see evil and
good cannot occupy the same space
listen to me carefully
evil
and good
cannot occupy the same space
at the same time
that's why jesus says a good tree bring
it forth one
good fruit it can't bring good and bad
and so he writes the law
here
by placing the law in the heart what
goes out
when the law goes in
you're right but that's not what i want
okay let's look at it this way
before christ comes to you what's in the
heart
evil when he puts the law in what goes
up
the evil goes up
now something else begins to emerge what
is that the good and that goodness is
the righteousness
of christ
let me show you what i mean
go to
malachi 2. it's a 23 minutes to 8. when
did i say i'd let you go
was i serious when i said that
no
all right
malachi
chapter 2 let's read verse 6 now i want
you to concentrate on that verse
put your mind to it
let the holy spirit help you are you
there
read with me
the law of
was where
keep reading and iniquity was not found
okay
let's look at that closely
the law
of truth was where
in his mouth
because of that
iniquity was found in his lips
mouth and lips same thing
when the law
then the mouth is full of the law
there will not be iniquity be found in
that mouth
if i uh if i had a glass
just imagine this is a glass
and it's full to the brim
can it accommodate more material no it's
full to the brim for something else to
go in what's in has to do what come out
now
that's why jesus says
thou shalt love the love thy god how
with
to the brim
with all thy soul to the brimming with
all thy might to the brim with all thy
strength to the brim with all thy
understanding to the brim so that the
devil has no room to get his stuff in
but we love god halfway and the glasses
are full
and the devil says oh
there's a room there's a vacancy let me
occupy it
overcome evil
with good
the evil that's a threat to us is not
what people do publicly to us
it is the evil that lies within
and we must overcome that
with the goodness of christ which is
his righteousness
and christ's righteousness is christ
himself
within now having said that
go to john 15. let's read from verse
4. well from first one
our subject public and private
you see when
when you allow christ to change the evil
within
no one can
make you curse
no one can make you fight you can where
he bothered me so i cursed
no no no no no no no
you chose the curse
john chapter what did i say 15.
when the goodness of god the
righteousness of god is within
that is the power that controls your
speech your thinking your behavior and
mine john 15 reading from verse 1
i am the true vine
and my father is the husband man
every branch in me that beareth not
fruit he taketh away by the way it is
god that cleanses the church
the father
are you following me
it is the father
that cleanses the church
every branch in me that beareth not
fruit he taketh away and every branch
that it through he purchased it that it
may bring forth more fruit now you clean
through the word which i have spoken
unto you first four abide in me and i in
you pause
it has to work that way
you give yourself to christ
you in christ
christ in you how that works don't ask
me
but it works
i don't know how i breathe at night when
i make no conscious decision to breathe
i don't know
but i'm glad it works
are you following me i'm just glad it
works
abide in me
and i in you
as the branch cannot bear fruit of
itself remember the fruits we saw in
galatians 5 22 23
what were they love joy peace long
suffering gentleness goodness faith
meekness temperance as the branch cannot
bear those things of itself accepted by
me
and one of those things is goodness
no more can ye
accept he abide in me now notice what he
says in verse one
i am the one
ah the true vine ah
listen carefully
what does that tell you
if one is true
the one is false
go to john 6
john 6 who has it who's the quickest
person in this church who is
john 6
verse 32
yes my lovely sister verse 32 of john 6
then jesus said unto them what verily
verily i say to you
moses gave you not that bread
from heaven but my father gave with you
though
ah
which is this
now if moses gave the true bread what
does that tell you
come on come on you're too slow
if there's a true bread talk to me
there's a false bread
go to john 17
you know this first very well verse 3 of
john 17. and this is life eternal that
they might know thee come on
the only true god what does that tell
you
there's a false god
you see whenever god has something
the devil has something to match it
and the devil's virgin is never far from
god's version
and so jesus says
i
am the true vine
and my father
is the husband man now let's go to verse
four abide in me
in other words abide in what
read verse four in the light of verse
one and tell me what you're biting in
abide in me what's that
true but that's not what i want
look at first one
what does jesus say of himself
right now reverse forget
abide in me where are you abiding
which is what
the true vine
stay in me
the greek word by means is meno which
needs to stay to remain to continue be
consistent
don't visit
a lot of christians visit jesus
on sunday and sabbath we visit
and we leave at censor or whatever
jesus says stay
moving
am i too hard on you
move in
stay
abide in me
and i in you
because if you allow me i will stay
as the branch cannot bear fruit of
itself except it abide in the vine no
more can ye except you abide in me i am
divine verse five hear the branches he
that the bindeth in me stay that is the
challenge for the christian
to overcome evil
we must stay with the source of goodness
i am too fine i am divine you're the
branches he that the bindeth in me and i
in him the same bringeth forth much
fruit if you just visit you bring forth
nothing
now look at verse 7
read with me if what
if he abide in me come on
and my words abide in you
you see that's the same thing as christ
in you the word in you
his word
he's worth it
you look at me strangely
so he says is he abide in me
and my words abide in you ah
you shall ask what you will
and it shall be done unto you
hearing is my father glorified
that you very much fruit because you're
abiding in me and i in you and this is
how we abide in christ
christ abides in us
and so it is a two-way transaction
as we talk about overcoming evil not the
evil people do to us but the evil that's
within us you know that evil that leads
to a suicidal kind of life and a
suicidal life is a life in which christ
is not at the controls
let me come in says jesus
i want to stay
you come to me and you stay in me
and if you stay in me we will overcome
that evil
your temple will change
my thinking will change my character
will be sweetened
people will not reckon this cannot be
the same man cannot be
a woman why because through the
indwelling christ
we have overcome
evil
[Music]
because as i said the worst evil is not
what people do to us it is what we do to
ourselves by not staying surrendered to
jesus christ
my brothers and sisters
public
and private
otherwise writes we have more to fear
from within
than without this applies tonight
our greatest danger is not what people
do to us
it is what we
do to ourselves
and so tonight
i appeal to you as your brother in
christ
abide in your savior
there is room at the cross for one more
and that room is for you
not your spouse
you
and christ is waiting tonight
there is we saw there's a true vine a
false vine true god false god true bread
false bread
listen to romans not romans john 14 27
just listening
peace
i leave with you
my peace i give unto you not as the
world give it because there's a peace
the world can give you i have a job i
have a 401k i have whatever i have you
know
everything is fine medical insurance
dental psychological everything is in
place i have peace
until one of them collapses
and then a peace goes with it
but the peace christ will give you is
the peace that allows you to sleep on a
boat when what is going on
a storm
the peace of god is not affected by
worldly circumstances
great peace of they
which love thy law and come on tell me
nothing shall offend them that's no joke
when you're truly a child of god people
will marvel how are you so calm
with all that's going on because i have
the peace and that peace is only
possible when there is no condemnation
upon us
there is therefore a great peace out
there which love thy law that will keep
him perfect peace whose mind is still
upon thee there's a peace
therefore being justified by faith we
have peace with god through our lord
jesus christ we overcome the evil within
by the goodness of jesus christ and that
goodness is his life his life was a
righteous
life so i call upon you in the name of
jesus
consciously
deliberately
as a personal action
recommit your life to christ
you simply say father i recommit my life
to you
let christ dwell in me anew
and overcome the evil that is that
carnal nature
this has to be done every day why
the carnal nature does not die
its
rain ends its rulership ends it does not
die it will only die when this mortal
come on
puts on
immortality that's why paul says in
romans 5 17 the flesh lusteth against
the spirit and the spirit against the
flesh and these are contrary one to the
other that battle goes on but we win in
the name of jesus why because we fight
in his power
goliath had
a sword
a staff
armor
armor bearer
david came in the name of jesus are you
following me
we have goliaths in us
we need to come in the name of jesus
thus
saith the lord
how many of you will say sincerely
genuinely and also online father i
recommit my life to you can i see your
right hand please
stand up with me
public and private our problem is not
the public harassment
it is the private within
we must overcome that with good and that
goodness is the life of christ how does
that life come into us by the living
word
why do i call it the living word
the bible says and god said let the
earth bring forth the living creature
after his kind the word of god made
living creatures
genesis 1 11 let the earth break forth
grasp the ear building seed god's word
created living
plants
genesis 1 28 let the waters bring forth
abundantly the moving creature that hath
life
by the word of god
how did god raise lazarus lazarus come
forth by the word
how will he raise the righteous dead
when he comes back but the lord himself
shall descend from heaven with a shout
with the voice of the archangel or the
trump of god and the dead in christ
shall rise for us he shall use his word
the goodness of god dwells in us through
the indwelling word and christ himself
is the word let us pray
father in heaven i try to make it clear
if i fail you come come before me god or
after me
and simplify it for your sons and
daughters whom you love in this building
and online
their god
help us to understand our greater danger
is not the evil people do to us
but the evil that is within us
but whether it's public or privately god
it must be overcome with good
and goodness is a quality of yours
father it's a gift of the spirit father
it is a characteristic of jesus it is a
divine quality it must be given to us
from outside and placed within
in the person of christ
represented by his spiritual word
as we leave tonight the god let us leave
knowing that the power to remain calm
under pressure
is the very presence of christ within us
as he dwells in his god he will deliver
enough to us this hatred for sin and
this love for right doing even in the
face of death like paul and stephen and
jesus christ himself
bless everyone who heard this message
dear god please bless them put a double
blessing on their children father i mean
these words
draw them closer to your bosom
save us when you come be god
in jesus name i pray let god's people
say amen and amen
god bless you
maybe
[Applause]
[Music]
you